vous nous disiez qui était le meilleur
et le pire chroniqueur pour vous pour
vous c'est qui alors le meilleur
chroniqueur pour moi c'est jean-luc
l'aurais déjà dit total
incontestablement passée voilà voulez
savoir le moins bon maintenant pourtant
avec celui passé pas loin où il celui
que voilà oui ouais bon week-end - ben
alors le moins bon ou la moins bonne
c'est jean-michel met alors à celui qui
travaille le moins je touchais
jean-michel il fait tellement rire mais
je sais pas effectivement il faudrait
qu'il apprenne à parler à ce qu'on le
comprenne bien tout ce qui dit et par sa
voix la mêlée charmant autrement bien
sûr alors moi c'est la culture la
connaissance autodérision la modernité
ce qui met la voiture et elle est même
assez moderne c'est isabelle morini bosc
ah ouais on aura quatre ans des danseurs
dans un sens cela dit pour vous aussi
voilà qui a été meilleur réellement bon
cette année un molière voilà alors au
niveau du flop alors c'est pas
intellectuellement parce qu'encore une
fois c'est la pondération c'est la
modération c'est gilles verdez non c'est
vraiment pour moi
son problème c'est gestuellement en fait
il n'est pas anormal ils contrôlent rien
contre le rien et vous savez quand il
avait pété un bloc de glace
voilà tout le monde avait pas je sais je
me rappelle j'ai envie de lui péter moi
je l'adoré et gilles je vous dis la
vérité et je le dis devant tout le monde
jeu il sait que je laime vraiment
énormément c'est vrai et c'est un garçon
d'une gentillesse est vraiment sur un
garçon sur qui on peut compter d'une
fidélité incroyable
manger de confiance aveugle en gilles
verdez voilà je vous le dis ludivine moi
j'ai un autre regard parce que je suis
pas une chroniqueuse confirmé comme les
en même temps qu'aux bonnes gens notre
regard donc un regard un petit peu plus
de téléspectatrices mahb est est
exactement comme géraldine c'était
bizarre jusqu'à ces récents
positionnement sur le black risque que
moi j'ai vraiment trouvé assez
intolérable et j'ai pas compris pourquoi
il était si dégoûté parce qu'elle
comprenait pas que le monde entier en
face une affaire d'état donc isa et ma
pire chroniqueuse ma - benoît oui je
vous jure parce que les dents bien c'est
pas parce que alors c'est pas parce
qu'il est d'accord pas d'accord avec
vous sur un truc pour vous on doit
passer de meilleures à pire ben oui ben
non justement onesta au dialogue
c'est pas justement mais là c'est à ce
moment là vous avez vous bien la banque
est restée braque les matches horribles
mais bizarrement c'est s'améliore aussi
mortifiant ça je vous dis que j'ai un
regard véritablement différent et mon
meilleur chroniqueur à leur ceni pour le
train le travail oit ni pour ses
positionnements et ses opinions mais
pour l'humour et jus déclare l'os et je
lui décerne les oscars c'est matthieu
delormeau et non mais alors ça ça pour
une surprise alors ça prend beaucoup
fait des yeux pareil vous êtes aussi en
fait vous vous regardez pas les temps ci
mais j'aime l'ambiance voyait que
c'était un truc sérieux moi mais mathieu
est très bon aussi mauvaise qu'elle aime
tous souhaitent tous coptes et beaucoup
d'aisance en scène russe arrive pas on
non on en voit l'art on savoir qui
j'aime le plus alors ben moi j'ai une
petite chouchoute ses com géraldine
c'est notre fameux isabelle un oui pour
informer spontanée et naturelle donc
bravo ce dès samedi le trophée nominés
et concernant nous on le sait plus ou
moins enjoué pierre ménès ah oui un peu
bougon pas forcément déterminer il est
donc chargé une bonne photo
alors messieurs aux échos pierre est
très content d'être avec nous et il
s'éclate au prêt nous donc c'est ma mère
est née comme ça il ya des débris
partout il s'éclate dans le kernel tous
les clubs il est pareil mais c'est comme
ça c'est sa manière d'être
gilles verdez alors la meilleure elle me
manque elle n'est pas là c'est valérie
bénaïm revient très vite noyé les qu'on
aime aussi c'est vrai parce que même
quand elles s'étaient déguisés en
sorcières pour halloween à mes yeux ça
reste une fille le père gmac liquider le
pirée j'ai trouvé pire que matthieu
delormeau dans girl aussi il n'a pas osé
venir ce soir mais je lui dis quand même
en face et benjamin castaldi le pire de
tous parce qu'on comprend rien de ce qui
est dit et quand on comprend c'est
encore plus catastrophique va jamin
qu'un petit peu grippé et belge est
aussi que j'aimais énormément il le sait
il a alors moi le meilleur j'hésitais
entre géraldine m'agace obligé jean luc
et film ces choix de végétaux prix kaki
entre géraldine maxime et jean luc et
j'ai choisi jean luc pour sa pondération
son calme sa façon d'être dedans et en
même temps ailleurs mais c'est ce que me
dit ça dérape quand même de prendre de
prendre parti quand c'est nécessaire
mais est toujours avec retard et le pire
alors ça je vais aggraver mon cas auprès
de toi j magie divine
est ce que mon pire c est ici que je
l'adorent humainement c'est gilles pour
la faire de griezmann et pour la
crinière de lionne parce que je déteste
qu'on souffle sur les braises et quand
même de la polémique là ne doit pas y en
avoir assez sondage auquel chacun au
tsunami mathieu de l'ordre alors ça
c'est pas mal c'est pas ma préférée mais
est ce que c'est vrai que d'envoyer un
texto pour dire que je trouvais que
c'était le faisait que cet hymne dont
une heure c'est vrai potentiel mieux la
dire c'est vrai ça c'est vrai mais
vraiment bon alors vous allez dire oui
certes on amis et tout ça mais c'est
pâques c'est aussi pour ça que c'est mon
ami le meilleur ces braves gens me
chauffer même quand il est à la place de
mais il est ok ils jouent aux courants
permanents et constate plaisir
aujourd'hui
est ce qu'on veut on peut revoir
l'extrader katia aujourd'hui c'est la
dernière des cadeaux c'est cadeau
regarde là pour l'instant les barques à
son plus proche de broadway on va passer
à la deuxième catégorie le ciri moi
c'est leur droit jean ne peut plus
d'avoir fait monter donc c'est
jean-michel pour vous le meilleur
chroniqueur a vraiment il est cultivé il
est drôle franchement il n'a jamais eu
une à côté
bah voilà reconnaissent ex quand il est
pas dans l'émission il ya un truc en
moins paris tout toi moi je suis obligé
chez oui j'adorerais yeux c'est que
j'adore cette onction avec oui bah oui
ne lâche pas un dandy oui et pourtant il
fout rien mais c'est des fois en qualité
et leur le moins par donc justement j'ai
des gens qui ne sont pas là en sort un
petit pont - compte elle chante bien
elle danse bien vrai fait plein de
choses mais c'est pas ce qu'on lui
demande dans l'émission finalement et je
trouve que malheureusement voilà je
t'adore tu es jolie tattoo mais je n'ai
pas le souvenir d'une émission où tu es
eu une opinion très tranchées sur un
débat un truc vraiment aussi tiens c'est
bizarre qu'elle ait dit ça ou ou que tu
cites un animateur ou tu prennes
position tu es très jolie maintenant il
faut que tu c'est pas joli c'est pas un
métier
clément vous êtes production de
batteries et son avis est mon ami mais
je la mer après d'accord y'a pas
d'humains
agathe alors moi pour moi le meilleur
chroniqueur de qui fait sa meilleure
rentrée n'était pas moi du coup ça nous
met vous trouve très bon très bon
chroniqueur un après dans la vie est
là-bas votre gueule non il est imola
chemise or il est extrêmement concernés
il est toujours là très bon camarade et
il a décidé en plus des gens meurent
sans filtre non c'est benjamin castaldi
au jeu s'il a fait une super rentrée à
faire les happenings et adama dit la
vérité même du côté des spectateurs
c'est quand même une grosse star d'un
jour c'est jacques je n'en fais jamais
jamais dit non avec les rues qu'à faire
un truc à faire ce qu'on voit mais
franchement c'est vraiment garder
toujours enjoué c'est celui avec qui
sait attendre
on n'arrête pas je laime énormément et
vraiment il a vraiment pas la grosse
tête 5 du tout neuf c'est assez
incroyable
oui et rillieux à sa place auraient pris
7,7 place de chroniqueur comme il a su
le faire et servir les missions comme ça
et le pire c'est également
malheureusement benjamin castaldi
alors voilà un mois que ces sursauts de
popol simplement pour ces petits
problèmes gastriques et de flatulences
intempestives ça va se régler en 2018
jouissent d'écouter j'espère et puis là
il est en train de voilà je sais qu'il
est chez lui et bien apparemment ça ne
va pas très bien
il est fiévreux voila voila c'est la
mauvaise nouvelle vous moi c'est le
meilleur fou c'est mathieu 21 heures
elle ne savait pas qu'il ya une cité
voilà il vient pas souvent donc c'est
encore plus dur alors ils arrivèrent
désir de voir se mettre en phase avec
alors est ce que c'est vrai car on
trouve des vidéos peut-être trois fois
par semaine elle désire secrètement que
ça marche pas pas du tout nous lier
l'utile et rajoute qu'il est drôle il
est sincère dont il n'hésite pas se
cacher que les gens il est ainsi juste
dans ses critiques ainsi tonné mine de
rien comme beaucoup la télévision
et puis donne aussi beaucoup de sa
personne il se déguise i dont il fait
tout ce que j'ai avec bonne humeur et
mon chouchou qui l'est c'est que je les
aime beaucoup il times bientôt sur chez
vuitton en train de travailler et
mathieu aura son prime time en 2018 est
oui a précisé ça comme ça c'est vrai bah
attendez vous le savez où normalement on
travaille au tout ça fait trois ans
qu'on travaille bien
ça fait trois ans qu'on travaille parce
que pour moi vous n'étiez pas près de
sortir de bouffe sur nrj12 en prime time
elle n'est pas non plus vous lancer
comme ça dans la fosse aux lions après
avoir connu les chiens d'accord je
n'étais pas vous serez prendre 2018 et
premier semestre 2009 et le moins bon
c'est maxime même si je trouve qu'il
progresse énormément mais je trouve
qu'ils bossent pas assez en amont
c'est valable pour d'autres aussi un on
a déjà parlé mais voilà ils doivent tout
à l'heure à faire parler de vous oui
mais bon c est où là je trouve mais il
apporte de plus en plus d'infos il
progresse de jour en jour donc je pense
asphalte est le meilleur la fin d'année
c'est moins bon c'est moins bon d'accord
kelly alors justement moi je pense que
max est le meilleur et les deux là sont
décollées là et ça va là dont je sais
pas quoi elles seraient vos mains
énormément en amont il a eu beau y voit
seulement créerait pas le temps de vous
pécho
notamment il a des infos de plus en plus
pertinente et voilà pour moi c'est le
jir vous entendez vous ce qui se passe
d'accord le moins bon et le moins bon
c'est jean louis amédée lathoud trop
lourdingue ces gens me away qui a besoin
que les femmes vous ne vous aime pas et
voici leurs sources et cassé prénommé